this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello to our fellow simpletons welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together
we are the head simpletons you know what
i'm here with my future co-defendant
ryan nicodemus
what was i said you would sex like hey
can you be a uh just a heads up
i'm using you as a reference for like an
apartment that mariah and i are trying
to get yeah you were like at this point
i've already opted in to everything up
to and including
co-defendant what is what that means
we're both
charged for the murder ryan
man or for hoarding today we're talking
about hoarding
and you know it's it's fascinating i did
a
whole bunch of research when we were
writing love people use things
because there is a section in there it's
a much shorter section than uh
initially was but in doing that i read
so much about hoarding and so
i wanted to start today by this is a
heavy episode
talking about hoarding is heavy because
it's not just about clutter it goes
beyond
clutter so i thought we would start off
with some fun
morbid humor from diane wade over at
minimalist.org
minimalist.org our free local meetup
groups we have an online meetup group
and then we have
100 different cities in eight different
countries
over at minimalist.org it is free to
join
uh let's see so this is her facebook
comment occasion i'll just go on there
and i'll see what people are posting
maybe they're posting about their
progress or whatever
and she posted this meme and it said
i've never seen a hearse pulling a
u-hole behind it
doesn't that put things in perspective
yeah it certainly does we can't take it
with us yeah we can't
and by the way the absurdity of trying
to take it with you
yeah the u-haul on the hearse is like
i almost want that to be a book cover
for us at some point
remember we we drove a u-haul on our
first film minimalism
and um it was like a metaphor i mean it
was real as well talking about dealing
with some of
you know the things in our lives but it
was really a metaphor of like driving
around the middle of this beautiful
desert
gorgeous gorgeous area and
we just have this junk
yeah we're weighed down by john let's
talk about the clinical definition
of hoarding yeah we would start with
that so hoarding
they also called hoarding disorder
someone who has a difficult time getting
rid of things regardless
of actual value may be a hoarder
hoarding is sometimes considered a
subtype of
obsessive-compulsive disorder ocd
interesting
however and there's actually some
speculation around that there
not everyone agrees on that it makes
sense to me and i'll explain why i think
it makes sense yeah
because the other side of the the
spectrum we're not going to talk about
th them today but
spartan yeah and so if someone who can't
stop getting rid of things in fact
they terminate their relationships it
ends in a very similar way to hoarding
yeah where it ruins
their life they can't stop letting go
the meaning they can't hold on to
anything right yeah maybe we do a
separate episode about spartanness
and spartanism because that is a
fascinating
topic well you know anything taken to
the extreme is going to be detrimental
right
right right and so um people often think
of minimalism as
an extreme and it can be relative to the
cultural imperative but i would actually
say our culture is the extreme version
of
nature it has gotten away from our
nature yes
and so back to the text here however
hoarding refers to a disorder in which
someone
has difficulty getting rid of items
regardless of actual value
the hoarding definition provided by the
american psychiatric association further
clarifies
that hoarding is the persistent problem
of getting rid of possess
uh of getting rid of possessions that
can lead
to clutter and disrupt someone's ability
to use their living
or work spaces so people who can't get
rid of things
and it creates this clutter later on
today ryan i'm going to ask an important
question
are we all hoarders to some extent but i
think
maybe instead of asking that during the
lightning round this article might
might illuminate a little bit maybe we
are and let's talk about the differences
here
so compulsive hoarding is different from
collecting
because the items are not necessarily
displayed
nor do they necessarily have any
value hoarding can lead to the excessive
accumulation of items
eventually a person with hoarding
disorder may not be able to move
freely through their space wow until
recently hoarding disorder did not
receive much attention the diagnostic
and statistical manual of mental
disorders dsm-5
previously listed hoarding disorder as a
subtype or feature of other disorders
such as obsessive-compulsive disorder
interesting the most recent update to
the dsm-5
place hoarding disorder as its own
category
now ryan i want to go through the common
types of hoarding
these this is not all-encompassing but
these are the most common types
right you might be a hoarder if right in
fact do you want to read some of these
common types of hoarding
this is great so um yeah when i was
reading through this article
it was interesting be uh because some of
these things i didn't even associate
with hoarding but
now i do and it makes sense so the first
one is animal hoarding
animal hoarding most often begins with
good intentions of rescuing animals from
shelters or
bringing in stray animals someone who
hoards animals
is likely to accumulate more animals
than they can properly
take care of instead of giving away some
of their animals they continue to
acquire
new animals two of the most common forms
of animal hoarding
are cat and dog hoarding of course like
that makes sense
i think giraffe horning would be in the
top three maybe
maybe like uh parakeet would be top
three giraffes
um joe exotic was an animal hoarder
right oh yeah he was with tigers that's
absolutely true
is that true jordan would you would you
can you diagnose him with a hoarding
disorder
dr dr nomore um
can you hook me up with your giraffe
dealer
i would love to hoard giraffes um
however a person can hoard any animal
uh this makes me think about the show
hoarders
and yeah a lot a lot of them have
uh i think there's only one season on
netflix that mariah and i watched but
quite a few of them had dog hoarding not
really a cat
problem but yeah i think about uh we
lived in lebanon ohio there was the cat
lady
literally yeah yeah the chicken lady and
the chicken lady who had all the
chickens uh-huh
yeah and cats strangely oh yeah she did
have chickens and cats and she had a few
dogs
and yeah and and sauce is beautiful now
i can't believe how they were able to
like
yeah they restored by the way i didn't
tell you this so you know our text phone
number people could text us all the time
937-202-4654
someone texts me the other day in the
the town that we grew up in
just south of dayton ohio he said hey
i'm the city manager here
and uh here's a picture of the home
that's in your new documentary it's
being fixed up right now that's
incredible
yeah and it was like i was pretty sure
there were homeless squatters
living in the house when we were filming
it was for lessons now
it was torn apart yeah it looked like it
looked pretty bad yeah yeah you know
it's interesting
even with you know how uh
you know how poor you and your mom were
um she was she kept a pretty tidy house
like she's extremely tidy and
aesthetically pleased she was a
maximalist yeah and we we just did an
episode on maximalism over on
patreon yeah we did a whole maximalism
episode you can go check it out uh
patreon.com the minimalist it's over an
hour long
and we we talked about intentional
maximalists
and how one might actually benefit from
that lifestyle when could it be better
than minimalism in some respects
she still had a lot of stuff yes but it
was still very tidy like i never felt
like
your house was like extremely messy no
never she she was tidy especially when
she was sober yeah
all right let's move on to well by the
way this is this article here is from
the recovery village and so we'll put a
link to both articles we're mentioning
today in the show notes so the next type
is
bibliomania uh-oh i don't know why but i
think at wrestlemania when i
when i hear that book crazy basically
yeah yeah
yeah so people who engage i don't know
if you want to read every single one of
these in detail but yeah it's when you
hoard books it's book hoarding yeah
recording we hear from these people all
the time by the way right
and by the way i used to be i was never
an animal hoarder
but i was a book hoarder i had about 2
000 books at one point
and some of my father's books their old
books my mom's books books magazines too
yeah yeah yeah i count the magazines as
part of that collection
right yeah and here's the weird thing
like we say collection
and they say even hoarding is different
from collecting i think sometimes
we collect we say we're collecting when
we're actually hoarding
yes they say the things have no value
but you know
everything has value to you if you're
holding on to it otherwise you wouldn't
be holding on to it anymore but it
doesn't mean it has value in the real
world meaning
someone in the marketplace is willing to
part with their money to
take that off of your hands right what
other kinds of hoarding do we have so we
got shopper hoarding
okay so it occurs when so shopper or
shopping hoarding occurs when someone
keeps every item that they've purchased
even if they don't use it so you know i
had this problem with my cell phones
where even though we worked at a
telecommunications company we still had
to pay for our phones a lot of the time
right and they're expensive man and uh
often like i don't know man people don't
understand
that a phone company they don't just
purchase a
blackberry or an iphone for 20 bucks i
mean they
it's there's a lot of money that goes
into it so even as someone who worked
there
we had to spend a lot of money when we
got a phone so i held on to all my
phones because there was this
perceived value of well man i spent you
know 300
on that phone right i don't want to
throw away 300
but the truth is as soon as you spend
300 on the phone
you've lost that 300 and you're probably
not going to get it back
you're lucky to get 50 sometimes yeah
especially with like
the blackberries that we were that i was
hoarding yeah right
and so the longer you hold on to it the
less you're going to get out of it
right and so shopping hoarding doesn't
take into
considerations the sunk cost fallacy
which you write about
extensively and love people use things
which will be out in july by the way i
love people use things.net if you want
to pre-order it that helps us out a lot
but
the the sunk cost fallacy but also when
we think of hoarding
the shopping hoarding is traditionally
what we're thinking of right
when we're not thinking of extreme
hoarding with the pets
so it's the shopping hoarding and i
would even say the bibliomania
is a type of shopping hoarding sure i i
don't know that i would delineate it
that much
they're they're material possessions
just like the clothes in your closet
the excess electronics in your drawer or
all of the
the junk in your junk drawer that you're
holding on to just in case
in fact if i were to rename this
category i would just call it justin
case hoarding
yeah by the way all those books i was
holding on to i was holding on to them
i'll read those just i'll hold on to
just in case i'm going to read them the
future they were aspirational
but that aspirational purchase i thought
it also made me
it was ego driven it made me look smart
to have 2 000 books
some of which i'd actually read most of
which i hadn't even cracked the cover
yeah so uh let me just read the last two
sentences here of this
shopper hoarding definition the objects
shopper
hoarders may have can be anything food
clothing photos televisions collectibles
etc
these purchases typically remain
unopened
still in their packages with price tags
attached
and this makes me think about there was
a friend of the family i'm not going to
use names
but her and her husband were very
affluent
they had amazing jobs they had a huge
house
they had a pool that we would always go
and visit um
but when you went inside it was it was
a lot of purchases that were unopened
and still had
uh price tags on them my mom when she
died um
i was going through her closet and there
were several things you know
the famously talk about the 14 coats at
winter coats in her
st petersburg florida closet right yeah
one of them was a fur coat
and so but the fur coat had a price tag
on it it was for like the goodwill but
still like
she was dying of cancer
and still we're trying to purchase
certainty right
yeah kapil gupta says everyone defaults
to their default
and which is a tautology but there's a
there's a profound truth in that
as well meaning like you
you become who you already are in a way
who you are at your fundament
you you are what you desire sometimes
what we say yeah
but if i were to open that at all i
would say
you are what your deepest desire is and
now your deepest desires can change
as you uncover what the truth of a
scenario is and i think sometimes people
hoard
at least in my case i was a hoarder and
i have ocd
there's no question about this and so
i'm speaking to you not from a place of
judgment
but speaking to you from a place of of
understanding
yeah and and so
i had a deep desire for pleasure
but i didn't really my deep desire at
the time was to run away from pain
was to hide from misery and so i did
that and i quite
literally but also figuratively covered
up
my misery with stuff and and the
the stuff hoarding buying things that
sometimes wouldn't come out of the box
or if they did i would set it aside in a
closet somewhere
out of sight out of mine and of course
the misery didn't go away it amplified
because
i was now going into debt or i was
spending money i didn't have to buy
things i
i didn't want i didn't actually desire
those things i desired
an end to the misery but i was never
going to get that from hoarding what
were you telling me
the other day about we are constantly
we're not running towards pleasure we're
running away from pain
yeah is that what you were yeah i say
that right yeah yeah and i think i think
the same thing is
is true with this this isn't this isn't
you don't ever see a pleasurable
like a elated hoarder right um
yeah that's a good point and when i was
hoarding now i have an organized order
right and so i had an ordinal system of
boxes and bins
and and a huge walk-in uh basement you
know
full-size basement full of stuff yeah
and
it wasn't because i was it was bringing
me joy or contentment or even pleasure
really
in the moment it might bring me a little
bit of twinge of pleasure but the
hedonic
adaptation takes it away almost
immediately 100
and so yes i was simply running from
the misery i i and i just wanted to stop
the misery for a moment and i figured
that that tag you or watch for 3 000
would do that for me and it didn't it
just brought a bill in every single
month which made me
more miserable yeah so the next uh the
next type of hoarding is food hoarding
so this kind of hoarding is particularly
wasteful food hoarding is when someone
brings home bags of groceries or
excessive amounts of food when their
refrigerator and cupboards
are already full the food may rot
attract rodents and bugs
and breed viruses or germs in addition
to buying excessive amounts of food
people with food hoarding disorders
usually don't throw away the food either
it's not uncommon for food hoarders
to have rotted food and piles around
their their house this makes me think of
the show hoarders and quite a few of
them were food hoarders
and this one man was like going you know
the
the therapist or like the organizer
whoever's there to help them go through
it
she's like there and she's like well
tell me about this food and he's like
i can't get rid of that food i mean look
how many families that would feed
and she's like this is these are expired
things
like you might be poisoning a family if
you found a family to give this to that
was in dire need
they probably would eat it but there's a
chance of like them being poisoned from
this food
right and he's like well i just don't
see it that way yeah you don't
right but that's that's when when i talk
about belief clouds the truth yeah
that's exactly what i mean by that and
so someone who
is hoarding food by the way i would
argue that most of us are food hoarders
sure go to your closets and cab or
cabinets and fridge right now
i i challenge you you might come to my
house and not find it but even sometimes
you'll find something that's expired in
my house
right that's food hoarding yeah and
and because it's not being deliberate
about the things that we hold on to
right yeah and so i have to be really
careful about that because
i used to have just i mean you would
have things that are three or four years
out of date you know
and but i'll hold on to it just the case
now why why do you do that sometimes
it's because you don't want to deal with
it
you're unwilling to deal with it yeah
but it has really nothing to do with a
willingness it has
to do with an understanding and what the
man that you're referencing
didn't understand is that
this was already it has gone beyond a
point where
it could be useful at all yeah and by
holding on to it it's just continuing
the misery and making it worse
yeah so then the next type is trash
hoarding
yeah um people with trash hoarding
disorders
not only savor keep piles of garbage
they often go through
other people's trash to find their own
treasures
that they'll bring back to their house
and again this causes a rodent pest
problem because of the rotting trash and
uh yeah it's there's a lot of there's
just danger with disease and germs and
things like that not just because of the
rotting trash but all of the
uh all the critters that it that it kind
of attracts
yeah and so we're calling this a you're
saying the problem with the
the thing is that hoarding is a type of
disease that's why i say it's not
it's not about simply decluttering how
to's aren't going to help you here
yeah because you could tell a hoarder
how to declutter their home
that doesn't that doesn't give them any
sort of leverage right and also just
telling them to take action isn't going
to do it either right
what the only thing that helps is a deep
understanding of
the problem and and the problem here
well
what is the problem it's fear of
uh not being enough i mean i think
ultimately
and unfortunately that's not in the
definition if i were to open the
definition
i would simply say that we hoard because
we fear that we are not
enough we become self-conscious
self-consciousness
by the way the only time that we're not
self-conscious is when we are
not ourselves meaning like when you when
you're in a flow state when you're
snowboarding ryan
there's a moment where you're never
thinking about self right
things are just happening yeah there's
no self-consciousness going on
right and and so hoarding is a is an
extreme
type of self-consciousness it's the ego
telling me that i am incomplete
and therefore these things whether it's
trash or
dogs or dead cats in the freezer as is
the joke and less is now right
you know my mom had a lot of stuff but i
didn't find any dead cats in her freezer
yeah but she owned 65 years worth of
accumulations
and i think many of us we hold on to
things not thinking that we're hoarding
in a moment we're going to get into the
five levels of hoarding
and then we can all identify what level
we are yeah
yeah so we got one more uh type here
paper hoarding
people living with a paper hoarding
disorder keeps all
types of paper like bills invoices books
magazines coupons junk mail photos
report cards receipts
recipes etc this is so common yeah
hoarding paper can be a fire hazard and
if a pile becomes large enough and
dangerous
a dangerous hazard that could fall on
someone so
this there's stories of people dying
because of like their stacks of
newspaper
falling on them yeah and suffocating
them or
better call saul season three season
finale yeah right spoiler alert um so
i mean that was another disorder that he
had but
the funny thing about these disorders is
a lot of disorders like this
aren't real in the sense that they're
not
tangible the same way cancer is you can
you can see the cancer in someone's body
right
but that doesn't make this any less of a
a disease right
and it's not me diagnosing anyone here
but it's simply saying when we say
disorder
break the word down not order
disorder chaos hoarding is the physical
manifestation of the internal chaos we
all
experience and that's why i say are we
all hoarders to some extent
well yeah we all experience chaos to
some extent
and sometimes oftentimes especially in
our culture
it manifests through physical stuff
ryan i'd like to go into some of the
symptoms of hoarding you want to talk
about that real quick yeah we can do
that um
so hoarding symptoms include the
inability to discard possessions
and experiencing significant anxiety
at the thought or attempt to discard
items
a person with hoarding disorder likely
has difficulty keeping their possessions
organized and may feel embarrassment
over the disorder
of their living spaces you know so many
people are embarrassed
when we go out and tour when we're
allowed to do that
um we'd go out and we'd stay at people's
houses quite often you know especially
early on we didn't have much money we
couldn't afford a hotel room
and so people like lent us their guest
bedroom where they have these big houses
or whatever
and the first thing as soon as we get
we'll get to the door what do they tell
us ryan
don't judge yeah don't judge us no i'm
not a minimalist like you guys
right and and that's what you're talking
about here one of the symptoms is
embarrassment so and embarrassment is a
strong word but
but you can what are some synonyms for
embarrassment maybe just
doubt insecurity self-consciousness fear
self-consciousness if you're feeling
these things
that is a a low-grade symptom before you
know when they like
now that you go into a medical facility
that they or anywhere and they take your
temperature before you can walk in
yeah and they won't let you in even if
you have a low-grade fever right
right and so you have the the low-grade
fever equivalent of hoarding when
some of these these lesser forms of
embarrassment start peaking their head
into the picture here what are some of
the causes of
of hoarding so uh
i love your little note here well the
causes
i'm sorry while what causes hoarding is
not known
it appears to have a genetic component
and then you have
it is known yeah you have the note here
of like no it's society
it is absolutely society yeah here's why
um
i was going to do this on the lightning
round as well but i thought this maybe
this is a perfect time to just
inject this this is from our new book
love people use
things there's a section in here ryan
called money is not the root of evil
so we're going to replace money with
stuff because it's just a different
resource
right yeah and so i think you can
replace money with any other resource
here
i'm just going to read this real quick
but we can talk about why society
is the cause
of hoarding yeah money seems to be the
biggest point of contention in most
relationships
we bicker argue and fight over household
spending and illogically it seems to
grow even more contentious
as we get more of it i read an
observational study a few years ago
about
the differences between our closest
primate ancestors bonobos
and chimpanzees while neither animal
uses currency
they behave very differently when it
comes to one of their most precious
resources
food like human babies the youngest
bonobos and chimps are both
eager to share their bananas with others
no
but their proclivities bifurcate as they
grow older
bonobos remain generous and they
continue to share their bananas with the
rest of their family and friends
well into adulthood chimps on the other
hand
hoard their bananas and will even use
violence to fight off others who attempt
to take one for themselves
what's even more fascinating is that
even when bonobos are persuaded by
humans to hoard they continue to be
generous
researchers gave bonobos the opportunity
to keep a pile of bananas for themselves
while a fellow bonobo watched from
behind a gate
but the altruistic bonobos always
chose to open the gate and share their
excess with friends
according to the researchers chimps
would never do this
they'd rather bicker and argue and
even fight if necessary does that sound
familiar
we adult humans tend to act more like
chimps
when it comes to our finances money
destroys marriages ends friendships and
breaks up business partnerships
this is why money gets a bad rap but it
doesn't have to be the boogeyman
unlike our primate ancestors we can
choose
how we behave with our resources instead
of clinging to everything
we can channel our inner bonobo money
isn't bad or evil just like stuff isn't
bad or evil it is merely an amplifier
money won't necessarily improve your
life but it will amplify your existing
behaviors
if you have quote unquote bad habits
then
more money will make your life
considerably worse
think of all the lottery winners who end
up worse off than they
than they were before they won and
if you're already a generous person then
more money can help you be
more loving caring and considerate
regardless of
your past behavior the choice is yours
today
are you going to be a chimpanzee or a
bonobo
choose carefully your relationships
depend on it that's great
i think that with the hoarding
thing and how this relates is are you
chimpanzee or bonobo
and i know for me for at least from age
14 to puberty of 13 puberty to
about age 29 or 30. i was a chimpanzee
and i would fight you for my stuff
yeah right and now i would just be
inconvenienced if
uh if like my house burned down like i
prefer that didn't happen
yeah but i wouldn't feel the attachment
to those things
and the need to accumulate those things
i'd replace them only because it would
make sense to replace my couch or my
coffee table or whatever yeah i wouldn't
feel um
the paying of sadness for losing the
thing
itself yeah let's talk ryan let's talk
about um
the uh how hoarding is diagnosed
okay so many people with hoarding
disorder
seek treatment for a co-occurring
disorder or
complication of hoarding disorders
once the clinical i'm sorry once the
clinician discovers
the excessive hoarding of items they can
explore the reasons for hoarding
and difficulties of partying with
possessions so i'm trying to understand
this
the basically someone is a hoarder
but they're so they're seeking treatment
for a
co-occurring disorder that that maybe
hoarding is a symptom of something else
that's going on is that what that's
saying yeah so you know when uh
a lot of people who die from the virus
that's going around
yes um they often say there are
co-morbidities
meaning um you know i i had that virus
and i didn't have a co-morbidity so
my chances of surviving it were much
better than if i were to have you know
diabetes or something like that right
lung respiratory
problems immunodeficiencies you know
whatever it might be
the same thing is true with with mental
disorders often mental disorders are
coupled right
and so my father was schizophrenic but
he was also bipolar
and so these disorders are often um
co-occurring
yes yes i see and and one often
fuels the other in in a roundabout way
yeah
hmm let's talk a bit about uh
interesting at the end of this before we
get into the five levels of hoarding
there are some hoarding statistics in
here let me actually grab this real
quick
so uh this one that stood out to me
because i
disagree with this with the statistic
okay right
and really the reason i disagree is
because it's how we
just define things researchers have
concluded that hoarding is more common
in older adults though it may
begin to develop in adolescence yeah i
mean
not really i mean i see little kids
where they have little collections of
things
but they never i've never seen a kid
who who doesn't
who isn't willing to share who isn't
willing to the
the kids are like bonobos in many ways
they are they are they are
self-absorbed there's no question about
that because they don't have a
prefrontal cortex
yeah i mean i certainly i'm just it's
i'm so torn because yes i do see
what you're saying with kids and sharing
but then also there is this mind
mind mind mind mind mine there is this
mind attitude that
uh kids will have like i remember i
don't know like my little cousins
they were one would play with something
and then the other one would like kick
and scream until they got that thing
and then they had it and then the other
cousin who was very laid back was like
okay i'll play with something else
then they would see them playing with
something they would kick and scream
right
until they could play with whatever uh
you know whatever their sibling was
playing with
um different different different things
but same actual same
underlying problem the problem there is
scarcity
or the idea of scarcity yeah the
scarcity mindset as opposed to the
abundance mindset
there's no hoarder that hasn't they have
an abundance of stuff but they don't
have any
abundance in their life well you could
tweet that podcast sean hoarders
do not have a hoarders have an abundance
of stuff but not an abundant life
right because the stuff has become their
life
right i'm not against obsession i think
obsession
is one of the best things that's ever
happened to me yeah it could be very
healthy
right and so so i have an obsession with
writing it gets me up quite often at 3
or 3 30 a.m
to write and i feel compelled to do it
regardless
of what the outcome is so obsession can
be as you said healthy
there can also be unhealthy obsessions
but i think those unhealthy obsessions
always have to do with scarcity and fear
yeah
and there's also a greed component in
there but even greed i think has
something to do with fear
absolutely absolutely and so here's the
stat hoarding
statistics indicate a prevalence of
almost four percent of the general
population
yeah yeah i think it's the opposite i
think it's probably about 96 percent
yeah and and you're going to see that
because we're going to go right now
into the five levels
of hoarding and guidelines for this
interesting the disorder
this was interesting now this is also
from the recovery village linked to this
in
the show notes yeah so we've already
defined hoarding ryan
so what they're saying here though is
depending on how extreme a person's
hoarding is
the behavior can impact their physical
or emotional health
relationships financial and legal
stability
and professional aspirations here's what
i'll say ryan my version of hoarding
while it didn't fit into it wasn't stage
five hoarding
it certainly negatively affected
my physical and emotional health
certainly my emotional health
my relationships my finances
my stability and my professional
aspirations
yeah and why because i would say
creative aspirations it actually kept me
from being the creative person i wanted
to be because i needed to be corporate
jfm
in order to justify the uh or in order
to
to supply the lifestyle i had created
for myself yeah
there's more than one type of hoarding
disorder there are several different
levels of hoarding that identify the
severity of a person's disorder
the national study group on compulsive
disorganization
what a group the national study group on
compulsive disorganization
created a clutter hoarding scale with
five levels of hoarding there's a nice
chart that we're going to go through
here you can
find that in the in this article in the
show notes understanding each level of
hoarding
can help people understand how to help
those
affected by the condition ryan let's go
through these levels
level one there are two things here by
the way um
we're gonna go through levels one
through five and if you're looking at
this here on the video you can kind of
see this chart actually ryan hold yours
up
yeah it's really well done actually it's
very simple to follow
um yeah we'll get into it it's really
interesting so what is a level one
hoarder ryan
so you have uh two of these uh two of
these symptoms
checked so uh you have light amounts of
clutter
and no noticeable odors what a way to
describe it
yeah now ryan has some noticeable odors
sometimes so does that make him level
two
yeah you know here's the weird thing i
think what can happen is you could be
level one
yeah and maybe not have or you could be
level two for example and not have all
the criteria but you can have
some of these in fact but you could also
have maybe a criteria from level five
sure for whatever reason and we'll go
through some of these yeah that's a good
point
so so the second thing checked is all
doors and stairways are accessible so
you have light amount of clutter
no noticeable odors uh and then all the
doors and stairways are accessible so
yeah that's interesting how it has all
because my doors and stairways are
accessible
um i have a junk drawer this is a little
bit
not yeah i mean and no noticeable odors
so i guess i'm a level one hoarder
yeah i mean i would actually say we were
both level one hoarders
and there may have been times where we
were actually level
two hoarders to some extent um
we were both level one hoarders maybe
one and a half yeah so what is a level
two hoarder what do they add besides
those two symptoms you already described
there
this is disturbing man uh pet waste on
the floor
yeah evidence of household rodents so
this is
level two we're not even a level five
like this to me is already kind of
extreme
yes um overflowing garbage cans
dirty food preparation surfaces
so i would say you had that you had
dirty food preparation services
sometimes just because you're
ryan uh is the messier half of the
minimalist
shirt sure but uh yeah but i was
i don't yeah i don't know man i kind of
disagree like if anything i would have
i would clean all my counters and then
i'd put the dishes in the sink and then
they might sit there for a day or two
right
and so to me when i see that as sitting
there for a day or two it's
it's just a piece of that so it's like
you were level 1.1
or something right yeah um well now
let's talk level three
you add three more symptoms into that oh
my god at least one
unusable bathroom or bedroom so you have
so much stuff in there
here's something weird ryan i actually
had an unusable bedroom at one point
really yeah so and you're talking about
uh when you were married
yeah yeah yeah so so the first time i
was married i we lived in the suburbs in
this big house
we had a we had three bedrooms one was
my office we had this third bedroom
that was basically a storage unit and so
when i say it was unusable it was still
neatly organized
yeah where your closet was where you had
all your shirts and
suits and everything that's the room
you're talking about no that was my
office
then there was the other room you never
went the door was always shut
it was upstairs and yeah it was it was
tidy so there weren't rodents and poop
and trash
but you didn't use it as a bedroom well
yeah that's the thing and by the way it
was unusable you couldn't use it as
anything other than storage
and so yes i would say that in a weird
way that makes me
i had i was level one but i had a
component of level three you were 1.3
there you go overflowing garbage cans
yeah i i didn't have that but there were
times where you had that occasionally
but it was
multiple it says cans oh wow i mean i
think
everyone plays like not everyone but i
think a lot of households play that game
where they're like
well i can still put a piece of trash on
top of there
yeah so i'm not going to i mean
that's uh i've yeah yeah so for me the
overflowing thing
is a metaphor in a way as well right
because their lives are overflowing
with trash yeah trash cans ryan do you
have a trash can or a trash
can't what's level four
do we no we didn't there's one more
odors throughout the house
ryan's always smelled like cool water
cologne
dude i love cold water
[Laughter]
oh man i forgot all about quarters that
was like my favorite cologne for a while
jordan so you don't wear cologne do you
you're the only sub let's see you're
only a sub 30 person i know
i know as soon as i turned i think 31
and we moved to montana
i was like yeah what am i we moved to
the colin wright who
is not a hippie-ish or spiritual or
whatever but
he was like yeah i don't wear deodorant
i'm like wait you could not wear a
deodorant and
still not smelly he's like yeah it's you
just shower
yeah and ever since i i mean it's been
almost a decade and i haven't worn
i haven't worn a deodorant yeah uh
likewise it's well you know
there's a for anyone listening to this
who's like these guys are crazy how can
they not wear deodorant there's a
there's a period transition period
there's a transition period where
it gets your sweat kind of gets really
bad and like you will stink a little bit
more and
you're like no i need to go back to
deodorant if you can get through that
transition period
then you your body will eventually
equalize at least with josh and i it did
the key is that if you start to get
sweaty
like you go to the sink and you got a
little rag and like you wash your pits
like i would wash my pits two or three
times a day during that transition
period
and now i only have to wash them once
once or twice a day
loves the way that i i smell i'm sure
mariah's same with you so there's the
whole pheromones thing as well and so
wearing deodorant wearing cologne
and some medical professionals even say
that
um oral birth control will really mess
up the pheromones that we emit
yeah um and so ryan i need you to stop
taking your oral birth control
never um he's just popping pills during
the podcast break
no um i'm not saying to stop doing that
obviously i'm just saying that
when when we cover up our pheromones one
of the accidental side effects is
we actually cover up the odor that
attracts the the people that
love us the most i love the way beck
smells if she gets real sweaty and
it gets awfully it goes out for a run
and comes back there's something about
her pheromones that that attract me
cool so when we say odors throughout the
house that's not what they're talking
about
they're they're talking about there's
odors of filth
the odors of filth whether it's like uh
well pet waste on the floor
or whether it's trash rotting food yeah
those are the smells that they're
talking about all right so level four
no cl we're adding to this list uh no
clean dishes or utensils
bugs more than one blocked exit
yeah and so growing up there was a time
where we had a blocked exit but it was
just because our house was situated but
you could argue that maybe there was
there there was it was unnecessary we
had a blocked exit now
it was an old door that you it didn't
make a whole lot of sense to use and so
like we put some stuff in front of it
but it was a blocked exit so
so you that exit was obviously intended
for use at one point otherwise they
wouldn't have built it there in the
first place
let's move on to level five the most
disturbing level okay so it's all these
things plus these last three things
uh at least four
at least four too many pets well at
least four too many
not for those four pads per local
regulations so what i
what's so silly about this
is that a you have to start with the
local regulation
which is gonna be different it's gonna
be like 20 or something right so there's
the local
and then if you have not one or two or
three over but
four over so what what if you have three
too many pets and that just keeps you to
level four
yeah you're fine um noticeable human
feces
yes and then the last one is rotting
i forget to flush one time ryan you
never let it go
rotting food on surfaces and inside a
non-working
refrigerator that's hyper specifically
but uh we've all seen it dude
here's the thing ryan you and i have
been doing this for 10 years and we've
been exposed to a lot of different
hoarders now
usually they're levels one two or three
and it doesn't go into the most extreme
level four level five with the human
waste pet waste
hoarding pets etc and so but that
doesn't mean that
it isn't disorder it is disorder i'm not
saying you have a disorder
i'm not diagnosing you with a disorder
what i'm saying is if there is chaos in
your life then by definition there is
disorder and so we're highlighting these
five
levels not to judge you but to say okay
if i'm feeling a particular way about my
stuff
it's because there's disorder there and
the good news is
if i truly understand it it's not just
about all right here
now to go download the minimalist rule
book there are 16 rules for living with
less
no no that's going to trap you you first
have to understand why
and then some of those rules the
decluttering whatever the how to's
may help you through it but
understanding fundamentally
what is going on here the scarcity
the fear the anxiety we default to our
default right
and right now we're defaulting to the
chimpanzee
mind and where we we need to accumulate
and yes you can be a well-organized
hoarder you can be an affluent hoarder
there is a correlation between an
inverse correlation between
hoarding and and income however
you and i have both seen hoarders who
make seven
figures a year they hoard differently
but it's still hoarding nonetheless in
fact sometimes having more resources
just allows you to hoard shinier objects
yeah i mean they still jump
it goes back to the folks that i was
talking about who were very affluent and
they had the shopping hoarding where
they just
bought but so yeah it shows up
in different ways and um yeah rich or
poor like people are affected
by this for sure for the sake of time
we'll take
marie's question over on the private
podcast this thursday she's from san
juan puerto rico and
she wants to know how do i address the
hoarding of a parent when i'm still
dependent on them
and living with them so podcast shawn
remind me of that
but let's send her a copy of everything
that remains
because uh it's the book that ryan and i
wrote everything that remains
is really about a story about my mom's
stuff is in there but
it's a story about going out on our own
eventually when we could no longer be
tethered there
we will answer marie's question
specifically on
the maximum episode over on patreon this
week though ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts go
to both of us
and during the lightning round this is
where ryan and i do our best to answer
every question with a short shareable
less than 140 character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if you'd like and now you can find all
of our minimal maxims
in one place thanks to our good friend
jessica lynne williams
she's our social media savant she keeps
she stores she hoards all of our minimal
maximums that's right at
minimalmaxims.com
all right sw wants to know
how does one become a hoarder looking
for tips
step one horde
how might your life be better with a
horde yeah
okay uh how does one become a hoarder
what starts the process
is it nature is it nurture so here's my
pithy answer for you letting go
is not something you do it's something
you stop doing and so if that's
if that's true i mean you stop clinging
well then hoarding is means you start
doing something
i know sometimes it's we hear
advice from self-improvement gurus or
whomever and and it's always about doing
something uh taking action of course
action is an important step and
and but when we take action first
without an understanding
we often take actions that move us in
the wrong direction
letting go is not something you do it's
not an action it is merely the
the stop the stopping of of the clinging
how do we do that well it's only
through understanding through immersion
through exposure
to the benefits of living with less and
so if the op
the opposite of that then is not being
exposed to the benefits of living with
less
how did i become a hoarder is the only
question i can answer here
and it's because i didn't understand
what enough
was how does one become a hoarder when
they think
they are not enough tweet that podcast
sean
so my pet the answer it's an oldie but a
goodie clutter is the physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
us
so yeah there's something much deeper
going on
so how does one become a hoarder what
starts the process i mean these
questions
are simple questions but there are very
deep and difficult answers and i think
with each quarter is going to be a
different answer
yeah but i think the commonality is that
there is something much deeper going on
and that that clutter is yes the
physical manifestation of whatever that
is that's going on inside someone
it's yeah it's uh it's i wish
you know there was there was something
where you'd be like well here's what it
is you had trauma in your life so now
you're a hoarder
and like and maybe that's true but it's
like it's so universal right
that yes we have all had trauma sure
undoubtedly even someone who grew up as
idyllic as
bex my wife she grew up on a farm in
minnesota
with middle class parents a dad's an
attorney a stay-at-home mom
her parents are still married yes still
married man
and married parents privilege right but
still there's always
even in those scenarios there may not be
this deep-seated trauma you know her
first memory isn't of her father
extinguishing a cigarette on her mother
like mine is
but the the the traumas still exist
nonetheless and
she while she may not be as predisposed
to become a hoarder she certainly could
there are plenty of people who grew up
in
quote unquote normal or seemingly normal
circumstances
who develop some sort of disorder up to
and including
and maybe even extending beyond a
hoarding disorder
all right before we get into our
listener comments and our added value by
the way ryan our added value this week i
brought three physical items since we're
talking about
minimalist i have three physical items i
want to run by you okay for our added
value segment because
the opposite of hoarding is not owning
nothing right you can tweet that podcast
sean
the opposite of hoarding is not owning
nothing and so i own things that add
value to my life i want to talk about a
few things that add value to my life not
necessarily prescribing them to use i'm
going to talk about those
on the added value segment today i
haven't brought a gift for you ryan
oh if you want and if not throw it back
in my face and spit on me i hope it's a
tie clip
so i can do that all right we got a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like
how do i get someone i love to recognize
that
she is a hoarder at what point
would our digital collections be
considered hoarding so a
digital hoarder that's one thing that we
didn't talk about on this episode for
sure
digital hoarding what's the 10-step plan
for addressing and overcoming hoarding
actual question we'll get into that and
although i think we can call a bit of a
plan
but we need to understand first plus we
have a horde of other questions
oh wow a good one about hoarding and
about decluttering and much more if you
want to hear all that listen to this
week's maximal episode on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
thursday
ryan and i record a much longer maximal
episode on the minimalist private
podcast we also do that whenever we have
a guest we have a
long-form maximal conversation with them
now what i realized ryan is that
there are private things in my life that
you and i don't talk about ever
just because it's private right yeah
like if um
well i'm gonna give you an example but
there are private things there are also
public things you and i just had a whole
public conversation now about hoarding
happy to talk about those things
publicly even some things that are
difficult to talk about i'm happy to
talk about them publicly like
childhood trauma there are there's this
middle space though
i don't know if you could call it like
semi-private or semi-public or maybe
it's both
but that's really the space of the
minimalist private podcast
it's like this semi public space but not
truly public it is a private podcast
and so it gives us the space that we
need to sort of mess up to
to talk about things that we wouldn't
talk about in a traditional
public sphere and sometimes in some ways
it's like
when a stand-up comedian goes on stage
and practice in front of a small crowd
instead of filming that and just put it
on youtube you
you wouldn't do that the first time that
you're you know just practicing
something or
the first time i write an essay or a
book or something i don't just hit
publish
like no there's there's a gestation
period right and so sometimes there's
first second third drafts over there but
it's a lot
a lot more role it's the minimalist
private podcast
you can visit the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal links so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app
if you enjoy our show and want to
support the minimalists this
is the only way our podcast earns any
money it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show 100
advertisement free plus private podcast
subscribers also gain access to
hundreds hundreds of hours of
past private archives ryan what else you
got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out
hi this is joe from dallas i was
listening to
some old podcasts here collection one
i'm a disc golfer and i used to have 500
plus discs
of which i had probably thrown 50 of
them more than one time i had a
big bag of putters 20 putters i used to
carry around to practice putting with
one day i bought a smaller bag so i
could walk around with the putters and
not have
quite as much weight only fit six
putters in it
uh i had forgotten my larger bag and
just had the smaller bag when i went out
to play the next time
and i had to grab five discs
to take on my round and i shaved four
strokes off of my best round
ever it was not a fluke i continued to
play with this smaller bag with only
five
a couple of drivers couple of mid ranges
couple of putters
and i kept getting between two and five
less than i had ever played before
i could only throw what i was really
comfortable with because that's the only
choice i had and i became a much
more skilled disc golfer by cutting down
those options
hi guys this is stephanie from harrison
ohio i'm calling in regard to your may
first episode
with rich roll about food i had a
comment and
an added value my comment is that was
really nice to hear from somebody who is
vegan
about keeping things simple because i've
transformed over the past few months
through my vegan journey and i've
discovered the same thing
that just keeping things simple when it
comes to food
makes things a whole lot easier it's not
as hard as what you might think in the
beginning
but in my beginning phase of becoming
vegan i did find
a blog and a cook and baker
who really adds a lot of value to
my my recipes
and what i chose to add to
my daily intake of food and her blog is
the minimalist baker
her idea is that she has the least
amount of
ingredients the least amount of tools to
make each recipe
and i have not had a bad recipe from her
blog yet you should check her out
all right joel for our added value
segment this week
we often talk about things that add
value to our life like experiences like
music or books
i i tend to think of those as
experiences you can have a physical item
you can buy a cassette tape
sure i think hipster
would just do it for the audio quality
man there's that audio hum
in the background of a cassette tape i
just love
but since we're talking about hoarding
today we just did a whole episode on
hoarding i don't wanna i don't want you
to think that
the opposite of hoarding is owning
nothing
it's not the opposite of hoarding
is being deliberate with the possessions
that we do have
consuming things deliberately things
that add value to my life
what does that mean it means it
increases my well-being in some way or
it brings me tranquility
right and so i have three objects here
that i've gotten value from
recently all that said these might be
things that add value to the minimalists
or at least at least half of the
minimalists but they may not add value
to you and so i'm not recommending you
go
buy these things now at least one of
these products
uh has offered to advertise on our
podcast before
and because our podcast is 100
advertisement free our youtube channel
is 100 advertisement free no average
no pre-roll nothing like that i just
said no but i do get immense value from
this particular product well there's a
difference between talking about things
organically like you're getting ready to
do and then having the obligation to
talk about something so
um yeah we would never put ourselves
under the obligation of having to
promote
a specific product right that would not
be genuine and it wouldn't feel good
right
right and it wouldn't feel good because
it wouldn't be genuine you're right
about that so all right so what do you
got where do i start here let me start
with this element
okay element is uh so
quite often we hear about electrolytes
right people people you've had
element before this one i've had
gatorade this is right with electrolytes
so we hear about electrolytes and it's
like well here drink this
terrible sugary drink that is unhealthy
for you because it's filled with sugar
and
maybe even food dye or whatever i don't
know what's in those
all the chemicals in those electrolyte
drinks well
this is an electrolyte powder that i
just put into water although there's
different flavors so the company here is
called
element and uh again not recommending it
for you but
it's a way that i get my electrolytes
every day so sodium potassium
magnesium in every single packet so what
do the electrolytes do for you
how do they help you out well they keep
you hydrated mostly and so
that's the biggest thing okay right and
so we are often
when we drink just water without any
minerals and other ways to get these
minerals as well you know if you
drink mountain valley sparkling water
for example can i have this pack
yeah you can have this now i'm going to
drink it during the break well let me
explain to you
okay what i do with this so they have a
bunch of different flavors my favorites
are the
no flavor it's just it's just sodium
potassium magnesium it tastes like salt
it makes your
water tastes a little bit salty okay so
i i enjoy that just because it's super
plain
and there's something that's so
satisfying especially if you're really
thirsty about that salt taste
it's not like drinking salt water it's
it's subtle they also have some flavors
that i put in cold water
like raspberry or orange or my wife's
favorite is
the uh lime and i keep some here at the
office as well so you all
jordan no more podcast shawn are welcome
to them as well however
the chocolate flavor it's a little bit
harder to stir in with water
because it has some cacao in it so i put
it in hot water
and it makes this hot chocolate that i
mean it's not
delicious sugary starbucks hot chocolate
but it's the it's just one pack nice a
healthy
hot chocolate and i'm getting all my
electrolytes for the day cool
so yes you can have that that is yours
so don't mix this with cold water though
i was literally gonna put in this glass
of water you can i wouldn't i would wait
until you have some hot water a little
bit of water and i even use one of those
little whisk things to stir it up
but you don't have to if you put it with
hot water it mixes really well i stopped
buying those whisk things because
everyone i've bought breaks like i've
never i i have a pretty uh
nice one that i did a lot of research on
because ella broke our last one bonus
product yeah
i don't know what it is so i'm not going
to tell you what that one is
this one is a cbd oil and so you know i
have this terrible disease and i'm in
tremendous pain almost every single day
yeah and the thing that has
kept me from being in crippling pain
throughout the the days this is
uh chris kelly actually is the one who
first told me about this
particular brand it's elixinol
a lexanol cbd now i use the i use their
sports gel
on my because i get really bad
inflammation in my joints my ankles
especially
especially if i eat any sort of fiber my
my ankles just really feel like they're
broken and so
i they have a sports gel that i put on
my ankles
again not a sponsorship would never ever
take any money from them i pay for these
just like you
would if you want them so what is it
about that particular because i
know medical grade basically okay
because i know you've tried a lot of
different cbd products yeah
and this one in particular i mean you
actually when we walked in here you said
i've never seen a bottle has 4 000
milligrams i mean it's a big bottle but
yeah it's not that big it's
uh but yeah you're right it's four fluid
ounces
and and but it's so it's heavily
concentrated although
i'm not again definitely don't recommend
this but one dropper
has 32 or 33. um
so this is tincture bottle here one
dropper has i think 33
milligrams i have found that's cbd
and this is thanks to our friend uh
then greenfield yes i get i get
deep i get more deep sleep at night
sometimes like i'll get which is
crazy but i'll get more deep sleep than
rem sleep
when i do like 100 to 200 milligrams of
cbd yeah and so uh in hi
that's a very high dose cbd so one dose
is 16 milligrams right
oh so so that's half a dropper okay
gotcha
uh and or maybe a 30 or whatever it's
about half a dropper
and and so that's one dose but you're
right because i have the extreme
inflammation
i am often doing 150 to 200 a day and i
have great deep sleep as a result
yeah um i well i will say no there's no
thc in this so it doesn't get you high
right i do feel
because i'm highly sensitive these kinds
of things i
feel a full sort of it's almost
i feel like a full-body calm in a way
where things don't get to me as much in
fact people
lately especially you have been like you
know you seem calmer lately or whatever
what's going on with you you seem so
much nicer
that's for more talk um yeah but there's
uh
this in particular has just uh has
made me less stressed in a way it's made
the things that really
uh bother me like our love people use
things trailer recently had
some someone copyright claimed and put
ads on the front of it because we
we paid to use their music but
apparently the agreement
who is a horrible company that we use
jordan what's their name
musicbed yeah yeah we use this to buy
a horrible company don't use them this
is the non-added value
yes this is the uh if you want to
increase uh if you want less tranquility
in your life use this company yeah
and so what what i realized with the
with the music
bed music that we used is they started
placing ads
we don't do ads on our youtube channel
we're
against ads we have an anti-advertising
stance
advertisements suck we'll never do ads
and yet someone else is putting ads on
there for us we're still trying to fix
it hopefully by the time this episode
comes out it will be
corrected yeah well typically like
because we go out of our way
to pay for the rights yes so we don't
have to do ads
right so uh yeah what sucks about this
company is we paid for the right to use
that
music and there's a clause that says
yeah well we can still screw you over
with that well they can't but the artist
who made it is now allowed to and it's
like well
but had i known that i wouldn't just not
done it right yeah it's like well yeah
okay read the fine print or whatever i
get it
yeah but if i have to read the fine
print you're not you're not a company i
want to do business 100
so third finally here the third thing
that has been adding value to my life
remember uh
three four years ago we were in
vancouver oh my god
uh i think it's around episode 100 maybe
it's episode 101. we'll put a link to it
in the show notes
dude we're in vancouver we have a uh we
have 50 city tour the
less is now tour we're giving a talk
we're we're walking around vancouver one
of our favorite cities just enjoying the
city and
and the people and it's me you and
podcast sean and
uh social jess we're doing a sound check
yeah
this venue solid venue enjoyed it
except they left the back door propped
open you left it cracked a little bit
and someone broke into our dressing room
stole my laptop bag with my passport
and everything else was in it and stole
jessica's entire everything she owned
you know it's funny
she we went back there because she had
to grab something out of her bag
and she was we were in the middle of
sound check so we were a little crunched
for time
and she had this like where's my bag
where's my bag where's my bag and i'm
like well
you know did you put it here there we're
looking for it she's like i'll just
worry about it later but there was
something
i was like this doesn't make sense like
something is up
uh and yeah long story short um we
noticed your bag was missing and then it
hit us like oh wow someone
had come into the back it's and that's
the only time they've ever had any issue
with anything like that in that
in that venue um yeah they someone came
in
they went into the green room because it
was right there by the the back exit
yep they saw two bags they grabbed them
and walked out and went to the local
park
yes now we got really lucky and so here
yeah here's what i
what i recognize is we got lucky in the
sense that if they would have just
hopped on
the train which was right next to the
park they would have been gone
my passport would have been gone i
wouldn't have known how to get back into
the country now
you know i because of the minimalist
journey we had been on
up until that point i didn't experience
misery
i experienced discontent i didn't have
the same panic i would have
seven years previous to that yeah but
it's really about the passport yeah the
passport thing is just like i mean
and yeah i think the computer's
replaceable everything's replaced but
the problem is you can't get back into
the united states without a passport
right and there's but the thing is has
it happened before has someone lost
their password sure so there has to be a
process i knew
that and by the way being stuck in
vancouver wouldn't be a bad thing anyway
right what a great city right and so i i
wasn't i wasn't worried
about that but i saw the sheer terror on
jessa's face
because literally all of her possessions
had been stolen her medications
everything or whatever i don't know if
it's medication supplements whatever it
was yeah yeah
a lot of her life was in that bag now
everything's replaceable
yes i mean you know if someone came to
us and held us at gunpoint
we would happily give them our things
and everything would be replaceable but
like what you're alluding to is
there was an inconvenience factor and
there's a product i wish i would have
had it
ahead of the moment because it's just
this tile tracker
and um i saw the i saw the kickstarter
for this so
this is so i did tracker before is it
gps
no let me let me explain okay sort of
but not really okay um
so i got these for you as well if you
want them sweet um
so had i had a tracker in my
bag i simply would have been able to
locate
the bag now there are two ways that you
can do that it's through bluetooth so if
it's within i don't 400 meters or
something then
you are able to find depending on the
device it's device specific
okay um but if for some reason it's out
of sight of your bluetooth then
it takes um it's
the what they call it the logic of
crowds or the wisdom of crowds
it's this is sort of the knowledge of
crowds really because
um what it does is it crowdsources
everyone else's
who who has tracker so for example in my
condo
apartment in l.a i
turned on the app and it was like there
are 9 400 people nearby with
with trackers so it is some here's how i
found out about this so
i previously used something called
tracker which is different from tile
so the brand i use now is is tile
and previously i used tracker but it
just didn't work very well
and so i started looking at the reviews
and comparing them reading articles and
i said oh
like it wasn't that i this technology
doesn't work well it's that that
particular brand didn't work well for
whatever reason
my batteries would die the the it didn't
connect with the app the app was not
very good
yeah so this connects with all the other
tiles basically
um no no it connects with other phones
okay
so like if uh and here's how i found out
about tile in particular
our uh acquaintance matt carney who had
a new song an album uh announced
recently
he the day his new song came out
powerless he
he had his car stolen oh my god and he
was on
like he was on instagram stories are
live or whatever
and he was he was talking about hey um i
so i've tracked my tile i i had a tile
in my car
and so he like he tracked it down
using the the tracking method this this
uses
he's like i don't know what to do now am
i supposed to confront this person do i
call the police
he called the police they ended up
settling it or whatever long story short
i i
he he the the tile he had was actually a
different stolen car so someone stole
another car and put his tile in there so
it's not foolproof but um what i've done
is that in my computer bag
in my luggage bag my packed bag
i now have a tracker in the or a tile
nose i had tracker that wasn't working
very
well but this has worked really well
also my keys my car
my wallet there's this wall so i got you
this wallet version here ryan
sweet and this goes in your wallet if
you want if not i'm sure podcast sean
no this is cool man jordan would like it
um no i like this you know a piece of me
wants to like put this on my bike
if it's possible yeah it is in fact they
have smaller ones called a
um i think it's called a sticker and so
you can buy you can buy different ones
and then here is like a for like the bag
bag
keychain whatever so yeah and and then
you just hook it up with the app and
here's the cool thing if you ever lose
your phone
you just you can double tap the uh the
that yeah that wait a minute um
yes you can double tap that and it will
ring my phone even if the phone is on
silent oh wow that's cool
yeah so you can set it up to do that
pretty cool so those are three things i
get value from
you may not get value from them at all i
don't recommend them in fact
you are already complete without them
oh by the way the electrolytes ryan yeah
the other thing that they do is if
you're dehydrated
you what symptoms do you get when you
get dehydrated you often get dry skin
dry eyes dry mouth and especially taking
a lot of cbd
yeah that you'll you'll start to feel
dehydrated by that so electrolytes
you know help with all the the sort of
dehydration symptoms like headache and
and things like that anytime i start to
get a little bit of a headache i'm like
oh
i might be dehydrated let me throw one
of these packets into it a glass of
water well i mean i remember dr ryan
green talking about when you wake up in
the morning
and how you're already dehydrated and
then you go to drink something like
coffee
yeah and you're just dehydrating
yourself more
water's the same way if it doesn't have
any minerals in it right
now this thing's making noises um yes it
is uh
yeah so it's interesting because yeah he
he recommended like
he kind of had this homemade electrolyte
drink that he was talking about with the
pink himalayan salt and some lemon juice
yeah that works that works really works
also yeah yeah yeah so um
no this is great i might add this to my
morning routine because my what i do now
is i have uh like the filtered water
through the berkey and i down like two
mason jars full of that first thing in
the morning before i drink anything else
that might be slightly dehydrating you
but interesting the way that you
correct that is just by putting a little
bit of minerals yeah yeah
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist we just
uh we recorded this last year jordan
let's talk about less
it's a video essay series what we did is
went back and edited six of my
essays from theminimalists.com and sort
of did this
this direct to camera video essay series
so
it's it's called let's talk about less
but each episode there's like let's talk
about minimalism let's talk about social
media
let's talk about technology let's talk
about impulse shopping
i really smile on your face i just
really want to do a salt and pepper
parody song of
let's talk about this baby let's talk
about
you and me let's talk about all the good
things something something that we can
rid ourselves of
he dropped the ball it's not there yet
it's not there yet bleep that out
blur his face
uh let's talk about less new video essay
series
you can find it on our youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the minimalist season one is going
up right
now so there's a few episodes out there
already i think my favorite might be
let's talk about social media but i
really like the way that jordan filmed
these and he is
i mean he's got so just uh
i mean he's obviously he's using his
talents in a way where he's he's
sharpening his skills and it really
shows
in this series let's talk about less
season one i can't wait to shoot
season two in the future you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram
at the minimalist come to one of our
live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com tour to find a
city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo
to podcasts at theminimalists.com and if
you leave
here today oh wait before you leave here
today if you want our show notes in your
inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com don't worry we won't
unsubscribe you we already did all that
well unless um unless you want to be
unsubscribed you can unsubscribe at any
time we'll never send you spam junk or
any of that other stuff but uh we will
send you our simple sunday emails as
well as our podcast
show notes no advertisements nothing
like that if you leave here today with
one message
let it be this love people
and horde things
wait a minute no use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it